اذبحوهم لا باس في ذلك ولكن تجنبوا ما
استطعتم تناثر دمهم في الفضاء حتى لا يلطخ
اقنعه الانسانيه على وجوهه هي جمله لم تقل
للاسرائيليين بهذه الصراحه السافره حتى
الان غير ان وحشيه قصفهم المستمر على قطاع
غزه لليوم الثاني عشر على التوالي تكاد
تؤكد على انهم سمعوا ما يشبهها منا بلغات
عده ابرزها الانجليزيه ولا يستبعد ان تكون
العربيه ايضا واحده
منها مجزره المستشفى المعمداني التي ادت
الى استشهاد مئات من الفلسطينيين غالبيتهم
الساحقه نساء واطفال فارون من بيوتهم
المدمره جاءت وسط مباركه امريكيه واوربيه
علنيه لما يوصف في لغه الساسه الغربيين
بحق اسرائيل في الدفاع عن
نفسها عيون الحزينه قبل هذه الجريمه
المروعه كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد امر
باخلاء مستشفيات غزه تحت طائله التهديد
بقصفها لكنه فضل ان ينكر مسؤوليته عنها
بعد صدمه العالم من وحشيتها ولا يبدو ان
رئيس حكومه الطوارئ بنيامين نتنياهو بذل
اي جهد يذكر لتسويق روايه الانكار عند
حلفاء ايدوا حملته العسكريه العاتيه
للقضاء على حركه حماس وقد له الدعم
السياسي والعسكري بل اعلنوا ارسال 2000 من
جنودهم
لمساندته لقد حزنت وغضبت بشان الانفجار في
المستشفى المعمداني امس ويبدو ان الجانب
الاخر هو من يقف وراء ذلك وليس
[موسيقى]
انتم تكررت هنا سرديه ثبت زيفها او ما
زالت تفتقر الى الدليل عن اطفال
اسرائيليين قتلوا بلا رحمه يوم السابع من
اكتوبر الجاري بينما بدت جدران القاعه
التي عقد فيها بايدن ونتنياهو مؤتمره
الصحفي عازله تماما لصرخات فلسطينيين
بالالوف يواصل العالم مشاهدتهم وسماعهم
على الهواء مباشره اثناء محاولاتهم
اليائسه لانتشال اشلاء اطفالهم من تحت
انقاض بيوتهم وقد دمرها القصف على
المستشفيات والمباني الس
في قطاع غزه يا سند انت حبيبتي ردي علي يا
اختي ردي هيي حرب عالميه ضد بقعه جغرافيه
صغيره وطالما وصفت بانها مجرد سجن كبير
سؤال ينبثق الان من اصطفاف دول الغرب خلف
اسرائيل بصوره تعيد التذكير بالجيش الذي
سبق الحرب على العراق عام 2003 تحت حجه
ثبت بطلانها لاحقا عن امتلاكه اسلحه دمار
شامل
الدبلوماسيه وحيث تشن الحرب الحاليه على
قطاع غزه بهدف معلن هو القضاء على حركه
حماس فان هناك هدفا اخر ظل طوال عشره ايام
مضت مجرد استنتاج لقراءات في عمليه
التدمير المترافقه مع دعوه السكان الى
الرحيل ثم تحول اليوم الى يقين لا يحتمل
الشك عندما اكده الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي بحضور المستشار الالماني اوف شولز
القادم توا من زياره دعم لاسرائيل انه هدف
تهجير اهل غزه قصرا الى بلدان الجوار وعلى
نحو يجدد النكبه مره اخرى وتحقق اسرائيل
فيه بعضا مما اخفقت في تحقيقه حين طردت
اباء هؤلاء واجدادهم من ديارهم وحولتهم
الى لاجئين في بقعه من ارض وطنهم توجد
صحراء النقب في اسرائيل
ممكن قوي يتم نقل الفلسطين لحتى تنتهي
اسرائيل من مهمتها المعلنه في
تصفيه المقاومه او الجماعات المسلحه لا
احد بين صناع قرار الحرب والتهجير باختلاف
اعراق ياتي على ذكر القانون الدولي الذي
يلزم دوله الاحتلال بحمايه السكان
المدنيين ويمنع ترحيلهم لا احد يشير الى
قرارات مجلس الامن الدولي التي تنص على
انسحاب اسرائيل من الضف الغربيه وقطاع غزه
لا احد يحكي كلمه عن حق الشعوب في تقرير
مصيرها وفي مقاومه الاحتلال لا احد ينظر
في عيون اطفاله ويتذكر حق اطفال
الفلسطينيين في حياه امنه كريمه لا احد
يستخلص درسا من تجارب الذبح التي ظل اهل
هذه البلاد يتعرضون لها ويخرجون منها
المره تلو الاخرى ليعلنوا استعصاء قضيتهم
على مؤامرات التصفيه وتم الرد
على مخططات الترويض ثم لا احد اخيرا يتحسب
لردود فعل مئات الملايين من العرب على ما
يظنه كثيرون منهم استهتارا بحقوقهم
واسترخاء لدم